are you sometimes prone to depression
where you go i need that rush of
adrenaline in order to get through my
day
honestly i can turn it on and turn it
off i'm very situational like i know
when i get on the set it's time to
turn it on right and when i when i'm at
home i'm just uh
[Music]
dad
right right and i don't i don't have a
longing like oh i wish i was doing
something crazy right now i love playing
with my kids i love taking them
skateboarding or taking i help coach my
son rocco's baseball team i'm the
pitching coach and i love it at what age
do your kids get to see
you doing these stunts because it's a
lot different than me watching it this
is their dad by and large they don't see
it
um i didn't even know rocco didn't even
know
that i did any kind of stunts the kids
didn't know i did any kindness they
thought i was just the embarrassing
dad silly dad and then one day rocco was
like six or seven and he comes home
we're sitting at the table he goes
jackass
and i was like
what
because we never brought that up to him
right his friends at school brought it
up and he wanted to know he's like let's
have this discussion because you're
keeping something from me
and i'm like yeah dad has a show where
he does silly pranks and stunts but
you can't really see it because it's
naughty and you know
but johnny don't you think in some way
you're all so proud of it and you'd want
to say to rocco yeah there's a weird
thing here i don't want you doing this
but i'm so [ __ ] proud of what i've
done because i made millions of people
laugh and i made a lot of money doing it
i am proud of
of jackass as silly as it is uh as
absurd as it is i am proud of it's
something that me and my friends did
together and we get to share with the
world and the world has responded they
like it and we never thought it could be
on the air as a tv show we never thought
anyone would come to the movies and
we're constantly surprised by the
success we have
but
at the end of the day i don't want my
son following in my footsteps